girls go home red wine is beautiful
welcome back to PewDiePie's revenge it's
not much of a revenger that I've said
all right this rush that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm just gonna run for it but what am I
where the [ __ ] am i doing it Oh what did
I do
what the [ __ ] did I do
see coming down all right no no no no no
no no no biggie yeah uh-huh
ha don't smack me with your buttocks the
dagger over to hell what the hell pity
don't [ __ ] gate yeah I bought I'm John
I'm so freakin pumped shot but don't
worry pity I got this
hey how you doing you come here often
that I um look at that ah what look at
that ha ha ha sounds right piggy yeah I
like it
what am I supposed to do with this to
destroy barrels voices oh come on
all right all right I got a plan I got a
plan don't worry don't worry don't worry
are you wired I'm Peter pie nothing cake
or rock all right ah yes we take the
dagger and then we
this is so bad
shut up mouth it's not even funny
you have to stop the bass Chaka maka
I've come now at least oh [ __ ]
well I kill old bells I thought that
would do something is there something
here I'm dying
oh no no no no no no no no no I better I
got a ham that's great Scott Alice
Bailey I see you I didn't quite add a
true Blair CC wait wait alright well
well I don't know pity you are not the
smartest person alive I don't think you
can do it I don't think you have it in
ya what stops I I'm just gettin paid
if you want to get out of this place you
gotta listen SuperDuper carefully all
right shut up all right
good times good times well I kill all
the barrels and I don't really I just
shut up thing you can stop moving now
I think I found a bug because when I
died uh-oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
that is not funny he's stupid he is
stepping that's fine with me all right
what not oh stop
what did I ever do to you how I don't
have like [ __ ] this I use this to
destroy battles
ah
just calamy yet took bare [ __ ] barrel
alright let's and then where there's so
many how love Wow what oh okay cool it's
actually kind of cool uh-oh I can get up
okay cool
we're fine we're still fine now we can
go through the throne room and finally
stop all the battles and save Stefano I
marry the princess and well I'm sure
well they're huge but that is huge
what are you doing on mr. chair you
[ __ ] disgrace
ah you do you think that dagger will
affect me your stop come on
just give me a break here please kind of
tired of all this
where am I I'm just gonna follow the
light
um goodbye like oh it's the father us
I'm SC bruh
so so not filling ice which I can't even
talk right hair is [ __ ] up because
it's hot loading keep loading man red
screen loading screen doesn't really do
much for me that's you and me and then
hurting screen
okay let's go what is this a bed ah the
nightmare was just a nightmare
oh that makes sense nah bro
yeah shut up
well was it fun I can move the bed
what there it is
I always hide it there because it's my
secret spot okay we can't go there
can we go over here yep where again
fantastic all right
I finally conjunct other to clear the
path block and exit users continue to
put the make sure and follow step fill
the container with pig blood I don't
want to do that use the burner to heat
the jar of a crate with a little number
alright well I want to remember that
anyway so I have to read it later and
stuff like that but that's a cool rock
back up back up dungeon hockey
cool I have to say he made a really good
job on this considering he made it just
for me
I feel honored I really did and it's
really well made it's done so it's cool
this aliens is way too light for my ears
it's really hurting my penis all right
sir I don't have anything do I
I don't have my lantern anymore well
that is [ __ ] creepy catch my iPod
powder crushed up I'm not gonna do it
I'm not gonna do it ah I do my face all
right what is it I don't like this I
don't like this at all
Oh more cars lovely oh it's kind of cool
mapping I like it
all right well not really oh really okay
why do we have oh okay
more room I'm getting tired of this all
we have to do is watch your prisoners
but it but the working editions groan
terrible the only source of heat the
furnace start
alright there's a bunch of clues there
yes yes [ __ ] Lantern man I miss you
bro
I miss your tip if you don't have a
voice but what are you doing they look
so awkward
okay ah oh [ __ ] it are you Flickr no no
no no no we don't like this
oh okay we're fine
no we're not fine give me that
no no no no no no no no
daddy fine I like a pity Chuck shopping
what am I supposed to go run around like
a miser like about oh my gosh
[ __ ] yeah
huh I [ __ ] I shed where am I suppose we
owe hallelujah wait
now you just [ __ ] come from there ah
son of a barrel [ __ ] that room [ __ ] that
room
[ __ ] it delight alright I don't know why
I did that
this is locked but I have a key yes okay
a chef's room well what oh hello master
dagger alright
and the calamine all right cool and
there was a bunch of other recipes I
guess they're not in here well I guess
that means we got to go down in the
water oh yeah why do you come in here
when I'm playing scare me so much ah
what tell me oh I can't really finish
now I guess I bite as well and this
upset sup
ah that is really weird ending and I
look like [ __ ] so that's good
like Bhushan yo just gotta go Rosie
Allison I slept over at ryback's Jasper
my shareable activate huh shut up shut
up
that's another toilet
I say yeah get him toilet lid blockage
ha ha no oh wow